once every three years leaders from all
over the americas meet at the only
gathering where all 36 countries sit at
the same table the summit of the
americas
but less than a week before president
joe biden is supposed to host his
regional peers in los angeles it's still
unclear who'll turn up
mexico took the lead by threatening to
boycott the summit after biden decided
to exclude cuba nicaragua and venezuela
arguing they don't meet the required
democratic credentials
no one has the right to exclude anyone
how can you call it a summit of the
americas where are the excluded
countries from another continent another
galaxy another planet
guatemala honduras and the caribbean
countries as a block are also
threatening not to attend while many of
those who will plan to protest
the reasons vary mexico's president
lopez obrador for example says that this
is a matter of respect for national
sovereignty while here in chile
president gabriel body says that
isolation and sanctions don't work and
instead calls for dialogue and
engagement with the leaders who are
accused of human rights violations
saying that they must be brought to the
table and brought to task face to face
this year's agenda focuses on reaching a
region-wide agreement on migration but
with midterm elections around the corner
biden doesn't want to antagonize
conservatives by inviting leaders from
countries that are viewed as
authoritarian
i think biden needs president lopez
obrador to come
because mexico is the most important
partner
of the united states in terms of trying
to control
the flow of migrants
but by ignoring regional demands for an
all-inclusive summit washington is
undermining the summit's agenda the
exclusion of some of the countries will
mean that that issue will be
centerpieced probably in the discussions
among presidents the failure to engage
to properly engage with latin american
countries is going to be costly
forbiding unfortunately for the u.s
other countries do see latin america as
a priority particularly china so i think
the only one celebrating the way this
summit is going is china cuba and
venezuela now say they won't go to the
summit even if invited a last-minute
face-saving deal that may allow lopez
obrador and the others to attend
but the damage may be done with many
arguing that a precious opportunity to
work with the united states as a partner
has been squandered
lucia newman al jazeera santiago